[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is that time of year again the time
of new beginnings new resolutions new
gym memberships maybe there is something
special about that 1159 on December 31st
every year that you can't quite describe
but you can feel it in the air that's
why we here at Rotten Tomatoes wanted to
celebrate the coming of the new year
with you by taking a look at New Year's
Eve as celebrated in the movies I'm
sorry Harry I know it's New Year's Eve I
know you're feeling lonely but you just
can't show up here tell me you love me
and expect that to make everything all
right
it doesn't work this way well how does
it work I don't know but no but this way
for this list movies needed to take
place during New Year's and offer one or
more iconic scenes around the holiday so
as you get ready to count down the ball
drop we'll be counting down our list of
the best New Year's movies all ranked by
Tomato Meter
[Music]
number 10 about time when Tim lake is 21
his father tells him a secret the men in
their family can travel through time
although he can't change history Tim
resolves to improve his life by getting
a girlfriend he meets Mary falls in love
and finally wins her heart via time
travel and a little cunning however as
his unusual life progresses Tim finds
that his special ability can't Shield
him and those that he loves from the
problems of ordinary life starring
Domino Gleason Rachel McAdams Bill Nye
and directed by Richard Curtis critics
say beautifully filmed and unabashedly
sincere about time finds director
Richard Curtis at his most sentimental
she's saying that you and
Granddad and his brothers could all
travel back in time absolutely and you
still do absolutely although it's not as
dramatic as it sounds it's only in my
own life I can only go to places where I
actually was and can remember I can't
kill Hitler or shag Helen of Troy
unfortunately okay stop
um
it's true which it isn't although it is
although it isn't obviously but if it
was which is not which it is which it
isn't but if it was how would I actually
how is the easy bit in fact you go into
a dark place big cupboards are very
useful generally toilets at a pinch then
you clench your fists like this think of
the moment you're going to and you'll
find yourself there
after a bit of a stumble and a rumble
and a tumble
wow is as good a reaction as any I think
I plumped for
but it was the 70s no this is so
obviously a joke it's not a joke
why would I lie to someone I'm
fairly fond of okay but when I come back
downstairs after standing in a Cupboard
with my fist clenched
you're going to be in so much trouble
well let's see shall we
number nine Bridget Jones Diary at the
start of the new year 32 year old
Bridget decides that it's time to take
control of her life and starts keeping a
diary now the most provocative erotic
and hysterical book on her bedside table
is the one she's writing with a taster
adventure and an opinion on every
subject from exercise to men to food to
sex and everything in between she's
turning the page on a whole new life
starring Renee Zellweger Colin Firth
Hugh Grant and directed by Sharon
McGuire critics say though there was
controversy over the choice of casting
Zellweger's Bridget Jones is a
sympathetic likable funny character
giving this romantic comedy a lot of
charm okay can we just
um
pop out there
for a moment
I just have something that
I want to say
um
you once said that you like me just as I
am and I just wanted to say
likewise
I mean your stupid things your mom buys
you tonight's another classic your
haughty and you always say the wrong
thing in every situation I seriously
believe that you should
rethink the length of your sidebands
you're a nice man
and
I like you
if you wanted to pop by sometime that
might be nice
more than nice
crikey
number eight Sleepless in Seattle after
the death of his wife Sam Baldwin moves
to Seattle with his son Jonah when Jonah
calls in to a talk radio program to find
a new wife for his father Sam grudgingly
gets on the line to discuss his feelings
Annie Reed a reporter in Baltimore hears
Sam speak and falls for him even though
she's engaged unsure where it will lead
she writes Sam a letter asking him to
meet her at the Empire State Building on
Valentine's Day starring Tom Hanks Meg
Ryan Bill Pullman and directed by Nora
Ephron critics say Sleepless in Seattle
is a cute classic with a very light
touch and real Chemistry Between the two
leads even when spending an entire movie
apart and just a few questions are you
sleeping at night
he doesn't sleep at all how do you know
that I live here Dad
look
it's Christmas
uh Maggie
uh
we really
she made everything beautiful
and it's It's just tough this this time
of year I mean any kid needs a mother
could it be that you need someone just
as much as Jonah does
yes
don't answer that let's get into that
right after these messages Sam Jonah
don't go away if you've just tuned in
we're talking to Sleepless in Seattle
and we'll be right back after this break
with your this new response
what is she talking about this is when
other people get to call in and dump on
what you said oh
this is really fun and helpful number
seven Trading Places
Upper Crust executive Louis winthorpe
III and down and out Hustler Billy Ray
Valentine are the subjects of a bet by
successful Brokers Mortimer and Randolph
Duke now an employee of the Dukes
winthorpe is framed by the brothers for
a crime that heating commit with the
siblings then installing the street
smart Valentine in his position when
winthorpe and Valentine uncover the
scheme they set out to turn the tables
on the Dukes starring Dan Aykroyd Eddie
Murphy Ralph Bellamy and directed by
John Landis critics say featuring Deft
interplay between Eddie Murphy and Dan
Aykroyd Trading Places is an immensely
appealing social satire
foreign
Happy New Year
in this country we say Happy New Year
thank you for collecting my English with
stings I am nanja ibako exchange student
from Cameroon
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh please
number six Diner Billy returns home to
Baltimore to serve as the best man at
his upcoming wedding of his childhood
buddy Eddie in the meantime he and Eddie
get together with their friends at the
local Diner where they trade stories
about their lives all they really want
to do is go back to being the Carefree
boys that they once were but they know
it cannot be they're funny and at times
revealing exchanges help each other face
a mounting responsibility of adulthood
starring Stephen Gutenberg Mickey Rourke
Kevin Bacon and directed by Barry
Levinson critics say Diner transports
audiences back to the 1950s with a
refreshing lack of sentimentality
evoking the thrill of everyday life with
its ensembles potent chemistry and an
authentic sense of spontaneity
hello Tess
um
I don't want to bother I just I just uh
want I wanted to say a few words
um I didn't I didn't prepare anything or
anything
the guys told me to come up and uh say a
few words I just I was thinking that you
know now that Eddie's getting married
and and uh
it won't really be hanging out with the
guys anymore and I just wanted to say
that we were never really that crazy
about you be quite honest I didn't want
to tell you sooner because uh you're a
sensitive person and and uh
I I just I just want to thank everybody
who's responsible for your being here uh
Elise I don't know if everybody knows
what Elise had to go through to get
married she was two points away from
spending the rest of her life by herself
it was very uh it was as I said and now
she knows uh more about football and
most girls in America it's uh it's
important to really
number five When Harry Met Sally in 1977
college graduates Harry Burns and Sally
Albright share a contentious car ride
from Chicago to New York during which
they argue about whether men and women
can ever truly be strictly platonic
friends Ten Years Later Harry and Sally
Meet Again at a bookstore and in the
company of their respective best friends
Jess and Marie attempt to stay friends
without sex becoming an issue between
them starring Billy Crystal Meg Ryan
Carrie Fisher and directed by Rob Reiner
critics say Rob Reiner's touching funny
film set a new standard for romantic
comedies and he was ably abetted by the
sharp interplay between Billy Crystal
and Meg Ryan
want to get some air yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
number four About a Boy a comedy drama
starring Hugh Grant as will a rich Child
free and irresponsible Londoner in his
30s who in search of available women
invents an imaginary son and starts
attending single parent meetings as a
result of one of his Liaisons he meets
Marcus an odd 12 year old boy with
problems at school gradually will and
Marcus become friends and as well
teaches Marcus how to be a cool kid
Marcus helps will to finally grow up
starring Hugh Grant Rachel Weiss Tony
Collette and directed by Chris and Paul
whites critics say about a boy benefits
tremendously from Hugh Grant's layered
performance as well as a funny moving
story that tugs at the heartstrings
without tilting into treacle the
interesting thing about me is I don't
actually do anything
you didn't do anything
actually no
nothing
[Music]
wow
that's um
now Rachel darling yeah
East Coast or West Coast rap oh God I
have absolutely there
she was gone there was no more to say
all rap music sounds exactly the same to
me
what I know a 12 year old would kill you
for saying that
really yeah so do I come to that are you
yeah what's yours called
mine
it's called Mars
mine's Ally Alistair
and there it was
it wasn't a lie it was 100 her
assumption
well 50 at the very least
number three the apartment Insurance
worker CeCe Baxter lenses Upper West
Side apartment to company bosses to use
for extramarital Affairs when his
manager Mr sheldrake begins using
Baxter's apartment in exchange for
promoting him Baxter is disappointed to
learn that sheldrake's mistress is Fran
kubilek the elevator girl at work whom
Baxter is interested in himself soon
Baxter must decide between the girl he
loves and the advancement of his career
starring Jack Lemon Shirley MacLean Fred
McMurray and directed by Billy Wilder
critics say director Billy Wilder's
customary cynicism is leaving here by
tender humor romance and genuine pathos
thank you
all right sorry I took so long on the
phone but we're all set all set for work
I rented a car to be here at one o'clock
we're driving down to Atlantic City
oh I know what's up drag but you can't
find a hotel room in town not on New
Year's Eve
we're not the old year ringing the new
ring a ding ding
I didn't plan it this way friend
actually it's all Baxters
Baxter hey wouldn't give me the key to
the apartment
you wouldn't no he just walked out of me
quit threw that big fat job right in my
face
the nerve yeah into the punk after all I
did for him said I couldn't bring
anybody to the apartment especially not
miss cubely
what's he got against you anyway
I guess that's the way it crumbles
cookie wise
number two Carol Therese beloved spots
the beautiful elegant Carol perusing the
doll displays in a 1950s Manhattan
department store the two women develop a
fast bond that becomes a love with
complicated consequences starring at
Cape Blanchette Rooney Mara Sarah
Paulson and directed by Todd Haynes
critics say shaped by Todd haynes's deaf
Direction and powered by a strong cast
led by Cate Blanchett and Rooney Mara
Carol lives up to its groundbreaking
Source material
foreign
this this where's the Ladies Room honey
if you go back to the elevator and make
a right you can't miss it thank you
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the holiday
two women one from America and one from
Britain swap Homes at Christmas time
after bad breakups with their boyfriends
each woman finds romance with a local
man but realizes that the imminent
return home may end the relationship
starring Cameron Diaz Kate Winslet Jude
Law and directed by Nancy Myers critics
say while it's certainly sweet and even
somewhat touching the holiday is so
thoroughly predictable that audiences
may end up opting for an early checkout
time
Brown
[Music]
Graham
you know
I was just thinking
why would I ever leave before New Year's
Eve that makes no sense at all
I mean you didn't exactly ask me out but
you did say you loved me
so I'm thinking I've got a date now
if you'll have me
I have the girl sneezies
sounds perfect
[Music]
Forrest Gump
slow-witted Forrest Gump has never
thought of himself as disadvantage and
thanks to his supportive mother he leads
anything but a restricted life whether
dominating on the Gridiron as a college
football star fighting in Vietnam or
captaining a shrimp boat Force inspires
people with his childlike optimism but
one person Forest cares about most may
be the most difficult to save his
childhood love the sweet but troubled
Jenny starring Tom Hanks Robin Wright
Gary Sinise and directed by Robert
zemeckis critics say Forrest Gump may be
an overly sentimental film with a
somewhat problematic message but its
sweetness and charm are usually enough
to approximate true depth and Grace
[Music]
ripping votes who gives us about
shrimping though I gotta buy me one of
them shrimp boats as soon as I have some
money I made me a promise to Bubba in
Vietnam but as soon as the war was over
we go in Partners he'd be the cat no
Shrimp Boat and I'd be his first mate
but now that he's dead that means I
gotta be the captain or shrimp boat
captain yes sir A promise is a promise
Lieutenant
now hear this
private guppier is gonna be a shrimp
boat captain
I'll tell you what Gilligan the days
that you are a shrimp boat captain I
will come and be your first mate
if you're ever a shrimp boat captain
that's a day I'm an astronaut
and finally number one in American in
Paris
Jerry Mulligan is an American xgi who
stays in post-war Paris to become a
painter and falls for the gaming charms
of Lies Bouvier however his paintings
come to the attention of Milo Roberts a
rich American heiress who is interested
in more than just art starring Gene
Kelly Leslie Karen Oscar Levant and
directed by Vincente Minelli critics say
the plot may be problematic but such
concerns are rendered Superfluous by
Gene Kelly and Leslie Caron star power
the gershwin's classic songs and
Vincente Minelli's colorful sympathetic
Direction
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody's always this wild I don't
know this is my first look at that
costume Jeremy Molly got a funny of mine
made me come here thanks to Jerry to
Jerry may his name survive his folly
it's barley what's he doing
he's about to give a show he's a painter
so what's wrong with that can I get it
in the neck so then why does he do it
he's got a sponsor he's got more now
than she has cash well Charmaine this is
farewell
say avoir it's Goodbye Forever by the
way I think you might like to know I'm
Jerry sponsor
I know you are
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next year I am your host nazarez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
and I hope that you have a very happy
New Year
foreign
[Music]